the Joe Rogan experience boom and we're
live with my pal Finney Sherman an
eight-time world muy Thai champion Liam
Harrison yeah [ __ ] you yeah dude great
to be here great to see ya a little bit
listen man I'm a big fan of all combat
sports but I really believe that if
there's one sport that doesn't get it to
do its Muay Thai I really don't
understand why it hasn't taken off in
America I don't get it I love boxing
boxing is a lot of fun
I think muy Thai is twice as fun yeah
it's twice as hard as well I think I
mean I fought pro boxing and I've and
over/under Muay Thai fights it's
definitely a lot harder I mean he's
getting more mainstream now along with
the MMA because most the top and male
fighters are doing Muay Thai for the
stand-up but he's still not where it
needs to be yeah it's weird right yeah I
mean I think what puts a lot of people
off my tie is the maybe the two-minute
break and also the two-minute break in
between rounds yeah and the traditional
music and stuff like that people find
the art to take to really which is I
mean I love it so I don't see that
problem but I can't see outside the box
with that as well so I feel like the
two-minute break gives guys more of a
chance to recover
it makes the fights more exciting you
have more energy and I don't care about
the the dance the Wai Kru that doesn't
bother me
you gotta fun on their martial arts
funding - sit down - I am baseball
baseball it's crazy how boring it is a
lot of shows in England now they start
to cut out all the traditional stuff
there's no Rama way to know my crude you
get a rink you face off Bell goes go
straight we're sort of trying to cut
little aspects of it out just to make it
more media but fun fun friendly ray yeah
we should probably explain to people
that don't know what we're talking about
though the dance that they do it's
called the Wai Kru right yeah they're my
and it's what's what is the headband
they put on was that the monk on that's
the Mong Kong and when you're doing the
dance the idea is like to warm up yeah
there's lots of different read lots of
different reasons why these different
counts believe different things student
mainly to do it bodies um sealing the
ring and then taking
you know the plane respects you Jim your
coaches your parents yeah I mean I enjoy
doing it
it prepares me mentally for what's about
to happen I've done it in Elliott all my
own dream eight fights only the odd one
or two where I've missed it when that's
only being because I've been told by the
promoters right no wrong way I enjoy
doing it but life in he said like some
people who come to watch it they'd want
to see fights they don't want to see
that aspect of the sport as well they
just want to see people getting torn up
and in case anybody didn't catch that
through that dense accent he just had a
hundred and eight fights that's [ __ ]
crazy man that's a lot of fight it is
for a westerner but a lot of the ties
I'm coming across there are two hundred
three hundred plus I remember last year
I fought a tie and they said all Liam's
at 100 fights that is a lot what do you
think and he said and Holland rifice
when I was 15 years old and I was sick
dumb who said that allow it so 105
minutes 15 how's it impossible I'm not
sure 52 weeks a year living isn't it so
yeah if you don't wait they don't in
Thailand if you don't fight you don't
wait so so yeah there's no welfare or
anything like that so they have to do
that I had former UFC champion Pat
Miletich in yesterday and we were
talking about Muay Thai and how crazy it
is that this one place Thailand
developed this completely effective
style like they changed the way people
fight I mean they really did did you
look at all the other martial arts
whether it's karate or kung fu or
anything else like they figured it out
yeah well but what's happening now is as
well the Westerners are starting to
catch him up now I mean remember the
first time I went to Thailand not many
people will go in and not many people
knew about fighting that's why we're
more and more Westerners now we're going
to live there to stay in there for long
periods of time
to get any down and we I can compete
with the top level Thais now wow before
I like back in the day there might have
been like only Rahman Decker
Danny Beal obviously John Wayne path
them guys but now there's a lot a lot
especially around Europe French fighters
top level British guys you got Danny
McGowan in England he's doing it I mean
we are starting to really compete with
people on top of top level now is more
time more popular in Europe than it is
in America
yeah there's massive shows on in Europe
every weekend really
in America dislike the main ones lion
fight yeah we've got like two or three
huge promotions in England now yah cow
the tank or the French they have massive
shows on every weekend with top
top-level fighters on all over Poland
and ever everywhere he's getting he's
getting huge I'm a big fan of lion fight
but it seems to me that there's a lot of
times where these guys come over and
they're fighting someone that really
doesn't belong in there with them and
you get to see like alert Zilla or
something like that that would be
absolutely ridiculous fight against the
guy was at 405 the best Thai champions
of this era it was yeah and his first
ever professional mortal ripped off yes
I've seen Yoko and everything else you
know they do it in such a way that the
matchmaking Brian called reduce a much
making our friend the fights are like
really real always always competitive
which I really enjoy and you've been
doing commentary for them for how long
I've been doing commentary for yah cows
since 2011
i'm estefanía and when I was working for
it's Showtime and she asked me to work
for them I still have some of the old
It's Showtime
on my old I have a DVR and my gym that's
like a [ __ ] 10 years old and I still
have your voice right yeah you know I
was gonna say as I've matured but after
the shenanigans we've got in the past
you'd be surprised but know it Sam you
know your car's gone from strength to
strength you know in it showtime
offshoots like glory and and infuse you
know I work for now you know it's so
healthy at the minute yes so healthy
kickboxing and muy tight
well it's so high level it's just to me
I mean I've sat down thought about this
alone by myself for hours on end trying
to think like what would be the way to
get more time more popular in America
because me as a person who loves combat
sports I look at my tie and I'm like
this is the pinnacle of striking sports
it's the most exciting to me I like the
clench I like the elbows I love
kickboxing I love glory but I feel like
there's something missing with that like
just the stuff that you were showing me
today with all the trips and sweeps and
all that stuff that's
eliminated from glory the thing is think
is really as well though because he's
got so
got a front friendly style you know he's
not particularly a clincher but he's
crash bang wallop in a 150 mile an hour
and I mean I'm not gonna lie I'm his
biggest fan
I mean if you listen to the common
traits totally a hundred percent biased
I mean I've known you since 15 I'm a
floor look how well he's lying down but
you know for me it's a style that makes
it exciting yes I think the TV thing I
think to get more popular need to pick
and choose what fights you're putting on
the TV yeah if you just put like a
random show on we've like free like
fights that are terrible but ones okay
you need to instead of it being live
maybe like pick and choose some good
fights get out there get people talking
about it make up thick wow did you see
that see them elbows see all that blood
see them sweeps that's why I yeah that's
what that's what I do personally but I
feel like if a network like Fox took a
chance and had one Saturday night and
they promoted it and then we're gonna
show you the most dangerous stand-up
strikers on the planet Earth like you
might think that professional boxers are
the most dangerous strikers but they
literally wouldn't last two rounds they
get the legs kicked out from under them
that get kneed in the body and elbowed
in the face that get cut up and clenched
and thrown to the ground it's just a
better style of fighting and a guy like
you have TV would be a whole lot of fun
I'm a big fan of the way fight man
you've you fight like you got rabies
I've always thought that that type of
style but you know what sometimes I
probably lost fights on points because
of going wanting to go for the kill when
probably I better change my game plan I
probably could have won but that's just
not what I'm about
[Applause]